Well, this morning
we are learning about a shift
in the Earth's inner core.
That sounds like the plot.
The Hollywood blockbuster.
Scientists say our planet solid
which is actually disconnected
from the rest of the Earth's lay
may actually have stopped rotati
and could even reverse course.
This is a new study.
It was published Monday
in the journal Nature
Geoscience, and its authors
who are based in Beijing,
took a very close
look at the seismic
waves from earthquakes
that have passed
through our planet's core
since the 1960s.
And that is how they were able
to calculate the speed
at which the inner core is spinn
Are you confused?
I am.
We're going to
get to understand this a little
better with our guests.
Let's bring in Michio Kaku.
He's a professor of theoretical
at the City University of New Yo
Professor, good morning.
Thank you. Morning. Glad to be o
What does this mean?
Well, at first
it sounds like something
from a Hollywood
movie script
says, oh, my God,
the core of the earth
is spinning backwards.
I mean, this is worse
than having a tsunami or an eart
The stability of what you walk o
is at stake.
Now, this report comes
not from Hollywood.
It comes from reputable scientis
at Beijing University.
They analyze echoes
when an earthquake takes place.
Shock waves
go reverberating
around the inside of the earth.
And by analyzing these echoes
with computers,
you can recreate a model of the
of the earth.
And sure enough,
the course
seems to be about to spin backwa
But I read that this happens
every 70 years,
so we don't need to be alarmed.
That's right.
The bad news is that we know ver
about the core of the Earth,
very little about what's underne
our feet.
The good news is probably
there's nothing to worry about
in the sense
that roughly every seven years o
we're not sure
the the
the center of the earth
does seem to go backwards.
If this is the core,
this is the crust, of the earth
that we live on. Yes.
This is the core of the Earth.
The core could move
independently of the crust.
That's the key.
So the point we're on never move
in reverse. Yeah.
So the core of the Earth system
and a pool of, like, molasses,
and it's able to spin
independently of the crust of th
So, in other words,
don't lose any sleep over this
probably is a natural cycle.
It takes place probably once
every 70 years or so.
But we need more data
because this is new territory fo
Yeah. Why do we need to know?
I mean, they spent a lot of time
They studied earthquakes
back to the sixties.
Why is it important to know
more about this
what are the implications?
The implications are potentially
because think of continental dri
Why are the continents moving aw
from each other?
What is driving it and also eart
The whole nature
of the stability of the planet i
We know very little
about what's underneath our feet
And that's why
this information from from Echo'
computer analyzes is very import
because it tells us
the future of the Earth.
What questions?
Finally, Professor,
does this leave you with?
Well, it leaves me with the frus
The head is under our feet.
Is this you can
you can almost touch it,
but it is thousands of miles dis
And we really don't know
that much about our home.
We know more about other planets
than we do
about the center of the Earth
thing, like Mars, for example,
is probably frozen over.
Not much earthquake activity at
So we know a fair amount about M
We know very little about the Ea
because the Earth is dynamic
Things are moving
and churning at the center of th
That's why we have earthquakes.
That's why we have continental
drift and volcanoes.
Yeah. Volcanoes. My son's favori
Oh, he likes to make it
with baking soda
and vinegar in the kitchen.
Thank you, Professor.
I now understand it much better.
Appreciate it.